[Music]
hey everybody
it's monday and we're finally finally
talking about
my friend dahmer yeah it's a good little
flick who recommended like somebody
recommended that we watch this i
this has been on my like to watch list
for like forever
and i just never got around to it and
then finally
um you know because i just signed up for
hulu probably like a month ago and i
just noticed like a couple days ago that
hulu had my friend dahmer so i said
[ __ ] finally i'm gonna watch this
[ __ ]
it came out in 2017 and i can't believe
it took me this long to see it
but you know better late than never i
suppose
they're in there joking about growth i'm
gonna make a shirt of me
[ __ ] like the hook busting out saying
the [ __ ] growth jenny thinks i got
tourette's syndrome
watch it's because it's only when i'm
voting i mean i was just laying there
like trying to doze off and then all of
a sudden he just yells a word like it
uh at random because i was asleep it's
kind of like talking in your seat just
you know
it's it's like talking in your sleep you
know when i'm going in and out i'm in a
hypnagogic state you know yeah
i i i get you yeah i don't know i don't
i don't do that i don't know why i do
what i'm daydreaming sometimes or just
you know
yeah because sometimes you're not asleep
sometimes you just do it like for the
hell of it yeah because sometimes you
don't you're doing other things like
you're in the shower or something like
that and all of a sudden you just like
damn damn yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] is
happening
shit's happening when i do that and your
imagination might be happening
internally it might be external i don't
know
it's when i'm relaxed and then something
happens or i think of something and i'm
like oh
you know god damn it my thoughts are
stronger than other people's thoughts
my thoughts and memories are far
stronger i think they are
they're enough to make a [ __ ]
physical change in in
me i'm like oh damn
like i got hit or something like
something yeah you know yeah he does
that all the time
yeah and then i think something bad
happened i'm just like what what
happened
like did you break something no i might
have realized something remembered
something or thought about something
okay it's all different it's all
different it all depends on what's going
on
it's only when i'm kind of relaxed yeah
yeah
i i gotcha yeah because i guess what
i guess the filters kind of go away when
i'm relaxed yeah you know what i mean so
my thoughts kind of can come out
will cause me to actually physically do
something like sleepwalking
yeah you know it's like it's like that
yeah i gotcha right
all right so uh you want to talk about
my friend dahmer
yeah why not this this is like
this was a super interesting movie it's
not it's not a horror movie necessarily
um and i find it interesting i would
love to know
if somebody saw this movie like in
another country
who didn't know who jeffrey dahmer was
perhaps even though i find that hard to
believe that and
like that there's anybody in the world
that doesn't know who jeffred ambrose
but i wonder how they would take this
movie like not knowing that this dude
turned out to be a serial killer because
it's essentially
i mean yeah it says at the very end that
you know
like they show him picking up his first
victim they don't show him killing
anybody
so it's kind of like this is just kind
of like his
awkward teenage years which i think was
a really interesting
kind of so this the yeah i mean i did
was uh that dude was uh
awkward his whole life though yeah i
don't know if there was much there
was no such thing as his awkward teenage
years that's how that [ __ ] was yeah
he was just like an awkward person
all around it's like nothing wrong with
being awkward a lot of people are
awkward but he was awkward in a very um
well when you have it in a very
particular way when you have a bunch of
damn
perverted motives and desires and
thoughts going on and that's what's
motivating you
of course you're going to walk around
all
[ __ ] shy you don't want anybody to
know what's going on
so you're going to feel insecure because
you're afraid you're going to get
rejected
yeah or you're going to find out what it
is you're thinking about yeah so you're
going to [ __ ] walk around all awkward
and uncomfortable you know boy if they
if they uh if they find out that i'm
thinking about having sex with these
dead bodies man
and eating them and [ __ ] they're not
gonna like that you know that's what
that's what
i mean at least they're self-aware
enough to know that they that that's bad
and that they shouldn't be thinking
about that
yeah he was a [ __ ] just some
gay dude that [ __ ] liked cutting
bodies up and eating people
and keeping buckets full of dicks
underneath the bed i mean you know yeah
you
you might want to be uncomfortable
around other people yeah i do kind of
feel like getting all off into that
yeah your jerk off materials a bunch of
[ __ ] dried up dicks
dick jerky yeah like beef jerky i mean
like i said
i'm willing to give people a lot of
leeway for whatever you know their weird
thoughts are their actual sexual
predilections but obviously there's a
line
[ __ ] a big point there's a line yeah the
line comes when you were hurting
people or animals sometimes just
fantasizing about it
is enough to to go like no you're [ __ ]
up
like i don't give a [ __ ] what you say
those vores people fantasizing about
eating people and
no they're [ __ ] up that is not a
normal
no you're [ __ ] up i mean they're
buying ovens and buying cooking
equipment and [ __ ] fantasizing that
they're gonna eat somebody
eventually those [ __ ] will do it
probably i mean i'm sure a small
percentage of them would sure
yeah i mean i imagine that most of them
are probably like wouldn't get around to
because they just wouldn't have
sorry the balls unquote unquote yeah
they're both awesome they're afraid of
getting caught but that's
right but yeah yeah the fact that you
would even like want to do that or like
seriously consider it yeah
then probably you need to get help you
know what i mean i'm going to say well
that's my orientation now you need to
get [ __ ] help
well that's what i said like if you're
if your
fantasies have to do with like hurting
other people like
non-consenting people or animals then
yeah that's a that's an issue
you gotta go get you some [ __ ] like i
said if everybody's into it and
everybody's
you know that's fine but other than that
yeah i don't know my hair's sticking up
really funny that's like
well that one german dude was into all
that four [ __ ] he found a dude that
wanted to be eaten
yeah so no they needed help those dudes
sorry so the thing well okay so the
thing about this movie is that
so the movie came out in 2017 but the
graphic novel
that it's based on which is also called
my friend dahmer which was written by uh
john durf bacter usually known as durf
um and he knew jeffrey dahmer in high
school
so he actually plays um you know a
character in this movie he's played by
alex wolf who if you don't know he was
also in hereditary among other things
um so he he plays that character in this
movie
and they show him like drawing you know
doing drawings of
uh jeffrey dahmer doing various dahmer
things doing a dahmer as they used to
call it
um and those were based on the drawings
that would later go on to be in the
graphic novel
now so okay now
i one thing i love about this is that
they got
the guy the kid that plays jeffrey
dahmer is ross lynch
and i guess i didn't know like a huge
amount about him but apparently he came
to
he's like quite famous for being like an
uh he was a actor on the disney channel
so he was in like a lot of disney shows
disney productions
uh stuff like that he's also a singer
and [ __ ] like that too
so they wanted somebody that could be
like jeffrey dahmer but also somebody
that was like playing against type
you know what i mean so it was somebody
it was kind of like what they did with
uh
zac efron playing ted bundy in that
netflix movie
where he's kind of like seen as like
this wholesome pretty boy type person
but they want to put him in this like
really horrible cd role
you know who kind of did that in another
movie who was kind of like this
you know was down robin williams when he
did that that's what i was thinking yeah
that he was creepy as [ __ ] in there i
mean when i see a [ __ ] up movie
one hour photo robin williams [ __ ]
does a performance of a lifetime as it's
[ __ ] creepy
that was the first movie that i saw him
in that i was like
wow he's like he can be scary if he
wants to because
prior to that he i mean i'd seen him in
like dead poets society and stuff like
that but he's always like kind of funny
yeah or like heartwarming he scared me
in that [ __ ] movie he was [ __ ]
creepy enough i can't believe that dude
killed himself
i believe it though because a lot of
comedians have issues
issues like that well because i mean
becoming a comedian
not as you know not always but generally
um if you have like a sense of humor
like that it's usually like a defense
mechanism
you're trying to everybody like that
dude he had a [ __ ] ton of money
well it just goes to show that it
doesn't matter yeah depression doesn't
care
yeah you know just saying yes it did
millennial man remember that or
millennium man where he played a robot
yeah yeah yeah that was a good one too
i kind of remember that i don't know if
i saw it but i remember seeing the
trailers and i got to get that movie
i'd like to see that one again yeah i
liked that one that's there's only two
movies i liked
you didn't like deadpool no i liked poet
society no
well i only saw bits of it i could i
just couldn't get into it oh it's good
i i i actually don't like robin williams
but i liked those movies yeah well i
associated from he was good back in the
day when he was young and he was just
some [ __ ] coke freak dude
[ __ ] working well yeah sure i get
that i used to like marketing
back in the day but yeah it's like in
small doses
because he was very like frenetic he's
cooked out he um
best dude on coke is mel brooks mel
brooks can get coked out [ __ ] have
you laughing but it didn't age too well
another one another goon was [ __ ]
martin steve martin was [ __ ] funny he
was coked up yeah
but that well the thing about it too i
think and um i can't remember but
robin williams was also in that movie
insomnia
which i think he might have played a bad
guy in that one too and that was also a
really good idea
if you haven't seen that one it's not
it's not the same it's not like because
i'm stephen king wrote a like
gigantic doorstop of a book called
insomnia it's not that it's just
had the same title but so yeah so
basically
my friend dahmer kind of concentrates on
jeffrey dahmer's high school
years and another thing that i did not
know
prior to watching this movie i only
found this out after
is that the house that they shot in
that was jeffrey dahmer's actual house
they shot in his actual house
like that he grew up in um so i thought
that was pretty amazing like in
ohio so it kind of covers i think it
starts
i think it's set in 1978 right because
it's kind of like his senior year it's
like it's you know a couple years of
high school
and it's basically just him being weird
like and you know interacting with his
parents and
it it's weird because his parents
were not and i think we talked about
this a little because we've done a show
about jeffrey dahmer before
but his parents were not necessarily
like abusive
really i mean they weren't physically
abusive obviously
um i feel like it was more a neglect
issue
i mean his mom had um god was she if she
had like bipolar or
narcissistic personality or something
like that she had like some kind of
and she portrayed they portray her as
very
uh i think ann hayes plays her in the
movie it's the funniest thing
you know it's somebody funny somebody i
think you named cowbell in the comics
in the comments said why would a photo
take an hour
why would
[Laughter]
back in the day it took time well one
hour photo was actually like really
quick
because you used to like way back in the
70s well
it was at least overnight yeah like
you'd have to drop it off and then it
would be like a day or two later and
you'd have to go through that
development
yeah because but then once they had that
big machine
that they could just like run this [ __ ]
through there like they didn't have to
yeah like put it all in the stop bath
and all that other kind of crap
people don't know what i'm talking about
i knew a kid that worked at one of those
looking little
one those little remember the old photo
mats that used to be a little tiny key
it was like in the parking lot
yeah uh straight he worked in one of
those for a couple years and during that
when he was in high school and during
that time he got a [ __ ] ton of nude
photos because people were taking nudes
of each other well yeah
not thinking that they were developed by
human hand [ __ ] they were making copies
and [ __ ]
of course making copies of everybody's
[ __ ] news yeah why did they think
they think like elves were in there
doing that [ __ ] it's like you know i
thought it was some kind of damn machine
that did it
well it is but i mean usually if you
work for
because even if you go to like walgreens
and [ __ ] like i don't even know if they
have it in there anymore but they used
to have the machine in the back and you
could see it
yeah um i think you're actually you're
supposed to check them to make sure they
came out
like before you put them in the envelope
they had people doing whole rolls and
nudes and [ __ ]
and they were back there making three or
four copies of which ones they were
really good [ __ ]
sharing them and [ __ ] and giving there
was no non-disclosure or privacy [ __ ]
agreement those [ __ ] got
copies of all your [ __ ] it's like funny
i was just thinking of [ __ ] man what
movie was it i know it was like a movie
from the 80s it might have been summer
school but i feel like it was like two
guys and they worked in a
in a photo mat and i remember that one
scene of them going oh it's more of the
redhead with the tattoo
yeah yeah so they were like making
copies of it i don't know why that just
would've happened all those hard copies
what are those where they probably got
guys out there with [ __ ] scrapbooks
and that [ __ ]
yeah it was like collecting those
collections of [ __ ] somebody's got your
girlfriend
and your wife getting it off back in the
80s in a second
with terrible hair in a big giant bush
they got pictures to prove
[Laughter]
somebody's like [ __ ] be jazzled yeah
like bush or whatever
somebody must have weird bdsm [ __ ] going
on in the photos they don't realize
people are [ __ ] looking at them
family dog jumping into the mix
[ __ ] yeah that escalated yeah some
real embarrassing [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i don't know well like i said i don't
know like if you want to take dirty
photos like back in the day it's like
obviously
you get a polaroid get a polaroid
because then you wouldn't have to take
it anywhere yeah the thing is is that
that's the serial killers used but the
[ __ ] yeah the uh the quality was real
bad
well yeah you couldn't get a great
picture with a polaroid i was you know
what i mean but
you know what are you gonna do that yeah
honestly the pictures the digital
cameras
revolutionize some [ __ ] people well yeah
yeah see back in the old days you
couldn't even take like naked photos you
know like this shitty
like you said it was like the shitty
serial killer photos yeah polaroid
unless unless you wanted like everybody
at [ __ ] eckerds to see your [ __ ]
pictures
that's funny but yeah so so they really
kind of go
into like his home life and
i kinda i really like um the guy that
plays his dad
uh i can't remember what the actor's
name is i've seen him in like a ton of
other [ __ ]
but um he come because his dad in her
life was like a chemist right which is
how he got all those chemicals for like
dissolving
all the the roadkill animals that he
found like so he could save all the
bones and stuff
and it seemed kind of sad because even
though his mom was like [ __ ] out to
lunch i mean she was
[ __ ] i don't know what the hell her
problem was but um
the dad really did seem aware
that there was something kind of the
matter with jeffrey
and he did seem to
kind of try to push him into being like
more normal but i think he didn't really
know
how to communicate with him and he
didn't really know how to be normal
because i guess his dad was kind of
nerdy too he was like kind of a science
nerd type of guy
so he was kind of trying to like
encourage jeffrey to not
be like him so he was always just kind
of like you know you need to go out and
make more friends here lift some weights
you know go
do some team sports so he did seem to be
aware that there was something
not right with jeffrey but i don't think
he knew
what to do i mean this is [ __ ] 70s
it's like so i don't think they really
knew i don't think they had any like
[ __ ] inkling of
of how bad it could get or how like
warped
his mind was you know what i'm saying
because it's just
you didn't really do that back then you
take your kid like a psychiatrist or put
him on medication or
it just wasn't done to any great extent
um so i just feel like everyone oh they
just thought he was awkward or geeky or
weird or whatever
and i don't think anybody really knew
like the extent of it
and one thing that i've seen a lot of
people discuss when they talk about this
movie and when they talk about jeffrey
dahmer
is that you know should we be
like i saw this one video earlier it's
like that
they're like well the movie was like
really good but it bothered them because
it's like well i feel like they want me
to sympathize
with jeffrey dahmer and i don't i can't
sympathize with jeffrey dahmer because
he was a monster
but i'm not sure if that's exactly what
the movie
is trying to do you know what i'm saying
to me it just looked like they were just
trying to tell the story
yeah i didn't really get the sense that
they were trying to make him
a victim um i think that they were just
kind of showing him the way he was he
was just a very awkward
person there was something to matter
with him and i think a lot of people
picked up on that even if they didn't
know what it was so i
you know yes you can sympathize with him
to a degree because it's like yeah
nobody likes to get picked on nobody
likes to be awkward or anything like
that
but it just kind of seems like that
was what happened and that's what he was
like and i think it's better
if we understand that serial killers
are people you know what i mean they do
have human qualities they're not
monsters or like they're not another
species you know
dahmer you know he was kind of different
in terms of you know your average serial
killer but yeah
he he there's a lot about him that makes
sense when you look at it from the point
of view
that the reason why he was awkward was
because of what he was thinking about
and he became awkward because of that
and then that further isolated him and
he would think more about that it was
like a vicious psych right
so he just went off into down parallel a
parallel universe of perversion really
is what you're talking about he's a
[ __ ] pervert
yeah that's what he was it's just that
very extreme perversion
yeah i mean and the thing about it he
said a matter of fact i remember
i remember um interviews with him he
said that too he said that he was
that he got deeper into perversion and
you know it was just
that's what it is i mean like i said he
didn't really have anybody even though
um you know the the time period that
they portray in this movie
where it does seem like he he seems like
he's trying to come out of his shell a
little bit and he starts hanging out
with
with durf and a couple of other high
school kids
but the problem with that is that even
though the kids he was hanging out with
were you know kind of popular
um the thing is they were hanging out
with him
prior to that he wasn't really bullied
maybe mildly bullied he was more just
kind of like ignored yeah you know what
i
mean
he was just like neglected yeah he was
just kind of like some kid that sat by
himself and no one really like
thought about him most of these guys
they come from a background in a social
situation
where they're they are of no consequence
right
so that's why they get that way uh
people that are [ __ ] bullied and
picked on a lot of times they end up
just becoming kind of like
forged on the anvil of chrome the
hardship [ __ ] pushes them into action
yeah and and also adapt and these guys
don't they kind of just regret yeah
they adapt and also i feel like people a
lot of times people that are bullied i
think in a lot of ways it makes you more
empathetic toward others
because you don't want to make anybody
else feel like that so it
in some ways you know what i mean but so
he wasn't you know he wasn't really
picked on
like a lot it was just that he was
mostly just inconsequential
and the fact that he started doing like
doing a dahmer like doing all that like
um where he was like pretending to have
like
seizures and stuff and then the fact
that these other guys thought it was
funny and that's how he could get
attention
i feel like that was kind of the only i
don't know i don't want to say that was
the only reason they were hanging out
with him is just because they thought he
was funnier like he was a clown
but it's almost kind of like i don't
even know if they really
liked him they just kept him around
because he was like
amusing or see what he was going to do
next but there's a lot of guys like that
yeah there are i remember a couple guys
like that as well it's
these guys are always a perfect storm of
a bunch of different shits oh yeah
so not just one thing you know um
but what what they usually have in
common is that they're ignored they're
of no consequence that's usually what it
is
and evidently that must be more
psychological
more psychologically damaging than
actually getting picked on
serial killers usually aren't picked off
now although a lot of them are
abused at home but it's usually like
parents or families yeah
and it's different kinds of abuse so um
i mean and jeffrey dahmer was not he was
even
kind of neglected at home yeah he it
wasn't a terrible home life there was
like a lot of strife like his parents
breaking up and stuff but they didn't
like beat him or anything
yeah and how they turn out usually
depends on what kind of abuse it is and
neglect is a form of abuse
it is and because he wasn't physically
abused or anything the neglect caused
him to just become very perverted
he wasn't very violent even as a serial
killer he just
drugged people and then strangled him he
just wanted the body he just wanted the
body he wasn't he wasn't like a face
he wasn't a prostitute a fighter he
wasn't a fighter he wasn't a process
right so he didn't get off on what he
wanted was torturing people
no what he wanted was a damn sex doll
that's all he wanted
he had a sex doll a real one that was
alive and wouldn't like him
yeah which is that's some perverted [ __ ]
it is
but like you said i like that you kind
of talked about the um
the cycle where he knew that there was
something the matter with him i was
reading something earlier that
you know everybody can talk about like
the serial killer in the nature nurture
thing
from what they've done of twin studies
which are you know admittedly limited
but they're talking maybe about 60 is
genetic and then 40
environmental um you know i know it's
kind of like productive to say that
because
uh you know genetic factors and
environmental factors kind of like you
know it's
they bounce off of each other like yeah
you know yeah so you got bad genes
you're up somewhere in appalachia and
that that environment
reinforces [ __ ] the selection that's
happening there well and
they kind of kind of go together and i
think what happened with jeffrey dahmer
too was that maybe genetically he had
something
wrong with him and the fact that he had
something wrong with him made people
react to him in a particular way that
made him you know
kind of isolate himself even more
because he you know felt like he was
getting rejected or something like
i'm weird and they know it you know what
i mean so that kind of causes you to
like
you know kind of go back farther into
yourself
and you don't and like i said as much as
as they showed in this movie and
like i said this movie from what i know
of jeffrey dahmer is fairly accurate
um to what his upbringing was like it
seemed like at least his dad
sort of made a little bit of effort to
you know
try to get him to come out of his shell
trying to get him to be more social
and like less awkward and less weird and
stuff
but i don't too late it was yeah by that
time he was already in high school
um i just feel like puberty is always
the key factor when it comes to male
serial killers
if they go through puberty with these
predilections it's kind of ingrained in
them from there on out
it becomes part of their sexual
orientation
and by that time he was dealing with all
these dead bodies
when i was a little kid me and all my
friends were looking for dead stuff
but what are you talking about seven and
eight yeah i feel like that's something
a lot of little kids do
because it's natural to be interested
let's go find a dead dog death and gross
things and stuff
it's gross this stinks you know yeah but
usually you know boys are starting to
get out of that
around you know 10 11 that's no longer
interesting
well he was all into that [ __ ] in high
by why why in high school you know what
i mean and if i can hit that's getting
kind of
fused in with his sexual orientation so
and the fact that he was trying to come
to terms with the fact that he was gay
when that wasn't really as accepted
back then i feel like when he was
growing particularly you know in the
early 70s particularly in ohio
um so i kind of feel like that was
another thing is he didn't really have
an outlet for that either
and they show there's a very awkward
like scene in this movie where
because you know it's very famously like
he kind of got obsessed with this dude
that would jog past his house a few
times a week
and he was actually gonna kill that guy
like he was like waiting for him one day
with like a bat or something and the guy
didn't walk by
now i'm not sure if this is accurate or
not but
in the movie he finds out that the guy
that jogs past his house that he's
obsessed with
is actually the doctor of one of his
high school friends so he basically like
kind of fakes an illness so he can go to
this doctor
and get the hernia test so because he
wants the doctor to like hold him
hold his balls while he's coming doctor
[ __ ] he dropped dropped his nuts on
him too it's like you're like i know
what you're doing
remember that [ __ ] looking at him well
because he got a boner they didn't show
it but it's like that was the
implication
yeah and then you know what i mean so
the fact that he had to
like go through all of these like kind
of convoluted ways to like to get
you know actually he had to get right
well and i think that he didn't really
understand it because like i said
i think back then growing up in the way
that he grew up i don't think he had any
framework
i don't know for that being 70s normal
quote unquote
70s there was a lot of gay action there
was but it's like that's kind of like a
big city thing he grew up in kind of
like
his location but i mean
[ __ ] man [ __ ] i can remember you know
back in the 80s
in high school we had kids we knew they
were gay you know what i mean
yeah nobody really [ __ ] with them from
what i remember
you know what i mean we didn't have we
didn't really have proof but you could
tell
another thing is is that even back in
military school you know when i was
that was middle school for me there were
kids that were gay
they weren't having sex but you could
tell they were gay yeah you know what i
mean we
weren't really sure what that was we
just admitted he's kind of a female
acting
you know what i mean [ __ ] that's what
we used to call it kind of a [ __ ]
that's what my grandma is he's like a
[ __ ] that's what we used to say
but we didn't know what a gay kid was
but looking back they were gay kids
and um they grew up they you know
[ __ ]
whatever happened that dude oh yeah he
was gay you know so some people i think
yeah
i think it's some people it's in them
from birth even my grandmother
i knew someone who was trans also yeah
in high school my grandmother came from
[ __ ] depression era mississippi
and a friend of the family
she said that kids she told me the kids
were born that way that she that
everybody knew that that kid was gay
as soon as he could talk yeah and that
he
he was gay grew up gay yeah and nobody
[ __ ] with him even really about back
then
really you know the whole gay angle
according to at least my family lore
which i think is
i think it's a reliable barometer of
what your average american mentality was
people even far as back as the 30s knew
all about gay
stuff knew that it existed they knew gay
people
they didn't really care if you were gay
what they what they didn't want is they
didn't want you outwardly expressing it
yeah i mean like you couldn't it was
kind of like a don't ask don't tell
policy
they knew about it but they just didn't
want people wearing it on their sleeves
or open they wanted
they wanted people kind of closeted yeah
and i think it was just
part of the social order but
what [ __ ] you know i mean just look at
star wars you know c-3po you got a gay
robot i mean they got a gay robot
[ __ ]
you know i didn't realize that that was
a gay character i didn't realize it was
a gay character at the time
but looking back on it of course that's
a gay character
yeah of course heather pio is gay i mean
he's not sexual he's asexual so they've
got a gay guy [ __ ]
playing the role they were gonna
originally have somebody else do the
voice acting and the voice actor that
did it says you know why don't you just
have daniels himself do it his voice is
perfect for that role
so and it was
[Laughter]
it was just i think it's always it's
always been around you can you can look
back at the silver screen of the 20s and
the 30s
and there's obviously gay characters in
there yeah just by
the way they talk the way they act
there's plenty of swish and evidently
everybody knew what that was
they just didn't openly discuss it yeah
it was just something you saw
megan said r2d2 was 3p as butt plus
i think it was a big butt plug it was a
laurel and party thing
it was it was a laurel and hardy thing
and there was kind of like
a kind of those two guys were not gay
but they were kind of like a gay couple
yeah
and in real life they were real close
friends they were married to women but
yeah they they were real close friends
it was it was almost kind of like a
like a celibate yeah or a platonic
gay i feel like anybody that works
together to that extent
is that close different stuff like that
they it does have
um you know aspects of like a romantic
relationship yeah
yeah that's just kind of there's a real
good movie about them uh
we saw it in the theater that's right
yeah yeah yeah and those dudes they were
straight
they were married to beautiful women
both of them were yeah um
but it was almost kind of like they were
almost kind of like they were married to
each other
their wives almost said that we're
basically coming yeah they basically
said that too like the way they sniped
at each other all the time they were
like a married couple yeah
it was like very very funny yeah so it's
always been around goes back to [ __ ]
forever and and
i think in dahmer's case i think it's an
excuse i don't think it was
it may have been a problem i think it
was a problem
to him to him well that's what i meant
but i don't think he would
i don't think he'd had a big problem you
know um
there was already a lot of that going on
it was all cool in music you know dave
bowie and
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] was going on and
it's the 70s was a pretty
sexually liberated time it was and and
but like i think it was just because of
his isolation
yeah i think the reason and it wasn't i
don't think it was just his sexuality i
think it was
him like wanting to play with death
that's what i was gonna say i don't
think it was the fact that he felt
different that he was gay
he felt different that he was gay and
that he was a necrophile
yeah that's what he was worried about
yeah if you ask me
and he wanted to [ __ ] bash people
over the head while they were jogging so
he could get their hands on their bodies
yeah you know so that yeah that's not
normal all persons like a sexual doctor
frankenstein
trying to get your dead body and turn
you into a living course yeah
and that's [ __ ] up and that you're
gonna feel [ __ ] weird when you think
you're going to realize you're very
different than other people
so no like i said it's weird though they
have that much self-awareness that they
know that that's bad and they should
keep it to themselves but i always
thought
when it came to dahmer i always thought
the gay angle was a [ __ ]
cop-out that's it wasn't that it was
that he was a gay necrophile
yeah that's what he that's why it was
hard on him
somebody mentioned earlier that um that
in interview with jeffrey dahmer's dad
lionel
that he said he wasn't initially alarmed
by
jeffrey being interested in all these
you know all the dead stuff was because
he's like oh you know maybe he'll go
into sciences it'll be like biology or
something like that which i guess like i
said
it's kind of hard and i know it's easy
to like blame the parents why didn't
they see it and everything and
you know yes a lot of serial killers had
[ __ ] up parents that were abusive and
stuff
on the other hand if you have a kid and
the kid is kind of weird or whatever
i don't think 99 of parents would not
it would not occur to them that their
kid might end up being a serial killer
especially in the 70s
i feel like nowadays maybe because where
because you know serial killer [ __ ] is
just like so
inundated in the culture it's like as
soon as you know you have a kid and they
deuce like some [ __ ] up kid you're
like well
serial killer you know what i mean they
even made movies about it but i feel
like in the 70s that wouldn't really
occur to you
i mean if you had a kid and he just did
weird [ __ ] like that maybe he you know
and his dad didn't seem like
the brightest bulb either so he was just
kind of like oh well
he's just interested in the sciences
that's all and it did
um he did actually go to the lengths of
you know because jeff had this little
shed like out in the woods where he
would go and do like all his
experimentation and he'd go and like
pick up dead animals and you know
dissolve him in acid so he could have
the bones and stuff
and his dad at one point did actually go
and like tear all the [ __ ] down and
throw all his [ __ ] away
and like be like you know go be a normal
person but like you said i think at that
point
it was too late for him to be a normal
person like somebody should have stepped
in a lot
sooner than that when he was like
[ __ ] 17 years old
because by that point i think it's too
late that yeah that ship had sailed
yeah by the research that i've done and
reading books that the fbi has written
about them usually they're
usually it's pretty much cast in stone
by the time they hit about 14.
yeah like you said once they go through
puberty
they're either going to be a serial
killer or they're not by that age after
14
it's almost too late it's part of them
yeah i mean i yeah i could totally see
that so it's you know
that's one thing that a lot of people
talk about they talk about dahmer
particularly but you know more than
other ones like ted bundy and [ __ ] like
that he was just like a [ __ ]
straight-up sociopath who had a totally
normal
upbringing and still ended up being a
[ __ ] psycho
now some but whatever sexual or that
serial killer's sexual orientation
there's a lot of guys have that but
never kill anybody too that's something
else that you have to
yeah the the guys that actually do
kill people it's probably a small
minority of them i bet you
it's probably less than a quarter of
them yeah i mean it's very rare
probably yeah it's probably only five
how much i got no date or anything but
it's probably about five percent that's
what i'm imagining
i would be surprised if it was even that
much yeah i think most of them
are like that but they don't ever act on
it because of self-preservation they
have some kind of discipline
well fantasize about it then when they
get to a certain age it burns out of
them they
because it's pretty well established
that
a serial killer himself will kind of
burn out yeah
as his [ __ ] testosterone drops his
sex drive drops and his
ability to fantasize about this kind of
goes away
so and i think that's around 50 yeah i
think it was the average yeah you don't
usually see
too many serial killers still active
after
that at 40 it starts to taper off and
then around 50 it's
pretty much gone usually i may live that
long
yeah i mean well the thing about it and
we've talked about a whole bunch of them
is they usually start really young even
if they don't start like killing people
young they'll usually start like
torturing animals and setting fires and
[ __ ] like that when they're
kids you know what i mean that's like a
red flag
but yeah so a lot of people like i said
have talked about jeffrey dahmer if
someone had intervened
before he was a teenager you know would
he have turned out to be a serial killer
still
you know obviously there's no way of
knowing that but
you know i don't know it's it's an
interesting
you know it's an interesting like way to
approach it and i'm kind of glad that
they made this movie
and they just like i said they end it
right when he's
picking up stephen hicks who was his
first victim
and then it just has like a thing that
says about you know the 17 people that
he killed
but it's just it's interesting that
they chose to just show what
you know what this what it's like like a
monster emerging like somebody said in
the comments
because you know what he did later on i
don't think like i said i don't think
the movie is necessarily asking you to
like empathize with him or go oh poor
jeffrey
it's not really doing that it's just
kind of like showing
what he was like and it's just it's
almost like a
like a cautionary tale or like an
instructive kind of hey
maybe you want to watch out for people
like this or someone needs to intervene
or something like that
you know what i mean i don't know but i
just i got that more than anything but
like i said this
it's a really good movie uh the acting's
all really good
um you know all the performances are
good it was that that kid that was in it
that played jeffrey dahmer was like
phenomenal i had never seen him i didn't
know he was like a disney channel guy
because he's like apparently like really
well known for that
and that was why they wanted him like i
said because it was like cast against
type and because he was so familiar for
being like so wholesome and everything
and they thought it would be interesting
for him to play a serial killer and he
did like an amazing job he looks a lot
like him
and he even had the walk down you know
the way that
that weird way that he walked hernandez
was asking about what he did yes he was
trying to make like living
zombie sex dolls yeah he was injecting
[ __ ]
um drano into holes into people's heads
uh that's he's trying to eat out certain
parts of their brain using that using
drano was it drano or was it no it was
was it drano or was it
uh windex or something might have been
dishwashing dishwasher
soap something like that i mean like i
said his dad was a chemist so he was
like super into like
experimenting with different chemical
cocktails yeah he was a [ __ ] bird
you know he wasn't particularly violent
though he
he usually killed him just by
strangulation he wasn't into torture
he didn't even like to see him suffer
from what he said he wasn't into that
he was just trying to render them into
into a living sex doll
yeah that's essentially what yeah he was
he was uh he wanted him i think he more
wanted him in a coma
he wanted him in a perpetual coma yeah
so he just wanted
to be able to do whatever he wanted to
them and that they couldn't leave
you see here's the thing he liked to do
dudes in the ass but he didn't want it
done to him that was one of the reasons
why he wanted him that way
yeah that's what he said okay so
okay yeah so yeah so the best and every
time he hooked up with a dude when he
got
later on when he went to school i think
when you get into college they wanted a
flip-flop
see he didn't want to well yeah fair
enough yeah you want a flip-flop he
you know he was just going to flip it
out of his pants and flap it down in
your mouth or something but he wasn't a
flip-flop
like that oh i haven't heard that phrase
in a while
he used to say that flip-flop
i'm gonna flip it over you see that [ __ ]
at the club the dude's trying to get bad
with me
yeah oh jesus christ all right so uh
yeah
all right sexual humor yeah yeah
don't ask don't tell [ __ ]
all that bisexual stuff i buy you some
[ __ ] and we get sex
[Laughter]
there's another shirt um but yeah so i
buy you [ __ ] and then we get sexual
that's a good one yeah yeah uh okay
so what was i saying oh yeah so if you
haven't seen my friend dahmer like i
said it took us like [ __ ]
three or four years to get around to
seeing it but we finally did um and it's
really really good like i said it's not
a horror movie it's more like a
coming-of-age
drama but it has like kind of
horror-esque elements just because you
know that the dude ended up a serial
killer
and um you know he does some kind of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in it but yeah it's
really really good it's on
hulu at the moment if you want to watch
it so check it out
and uh we will be back tomorrow talking
about yet another movie
so as usual thanks for dropping by and
we'll talk to you guys tomorrow
bye